jimmy fallon had governor cuomo
on his show monday night i tell you this
because otherwise no one would ever know
once again jim held andy's feet to the
fire hammering him on the preventable
deaths that occurred in new york's rest
homes
after he filled them with covid patients
nah just kidding
what phase of dating are you currently
in
zero i'm at phase zero on dating
uh this is
there's no duration on phase zero yeah
uh there is no automatic time that you
go to phase one you could stay at phase
zero
for months by the i think new york city
will be
fully reopened before i get out of phase
zero on dating uh i thank you so much
for your leadership
you were there for us when we needed you
you still are there
oh i feel as bad as jimmy fallon's hair
look i get it i'm told fallon hosts a
comedy show
but has there ever been a politician who
got more of a free ride from the press
and celebs than cuomo
even during the worst of his response he
had his own public relations arm over at
cnn
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have mounted
on the front of your pretty face do you
think
that you are an attractive person now
because you're single and ready to
mingle do you really think
you are some desirable single person i
think
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
wow that bit really killed literally
people
died during that sibling act but at
least someone over at cnn has
stones andrew cuomo seems to be on
something of a victory tour
congratulating the state and himself for
defeating the virus even selling this
poster
which shows his state getting over the
mountain by bringing down the curve
during the
111 days of hell as the governor put it
the poster includes references to his
daughters and a boyfriend little
inside jokes there are no illustrations
however of the more than 32
000 dead new yorkers the highest death
toll by far
of any state
well that's going to make things tense
at the cnn cafeteria
cuomo also said this we're just worried
that the infection is going to come from
the other states now
back to new york which would be a real
tragedy
it's already a tragedy at least for
america given that 65 percent of the
cases that spread throughout the country
originated from new york cuomo also
bragged about the state's declining
infection rate but that's what happens
when you run out of victims
still the media prefers to focus on
florida even though new york has eight
times as many deaths and nearly twice as
many infections and florida is roughly
the same population as new york
but the governor loves to smear florida
and oddly so does cnn
look at these headlines weird isn't it
but again florida is run by a republican
that chris cuomo's brother the governor
doesn't like
seems like a perfect story for a media
watchdog show called
reliable sources i'd say they're too
busy watching
fox kick their network's butt however
but unlike chris cuomo
i don't condone violence
all right jesse let's get to the
important point here fallon's hair
you're in shut down we're i'm in
shutdown
our hair looks great what is uh what's
going on with fallon
that looked like bed head but sometimes
if you're hollywood
you can bed head is a is the look so
i don't know i just want to know what
kind of conditioner he's using because
that looks like some nice flow
i i know i know we're a little tight on
time the only thing i'd say
about cuomo is trump made him a star
trump gave him everything he wanted
gave him ships gave him ppe and it was
like the trump and cuomo show for the
first part of this
the only really thing great that cuomo
did was he locked the city down
china style i mean that that was a very
vigilant lockdown
um even though he was late a little bit
and then he infected everybody in the
nursing home so
it's a it's you know it's a mixed record
and as a politician
you know politicians don't take
ownership they they pass
blame and that's what makes politicians
good politicians though
yeah dana isn't there anybody
like over at fallon or somewhere that
watches this this stuff
this love fest and go this is bad
television it's
disgusting at least to human beings
well and it's not like um there hasn't
been reporting about the nursing homes i
mean it's out there um
people can read about it if they if they
choose to but
it wasn't just fallon greg i watched cbs
sunday morning
quite often and jane paulie who now is
the
main anchor there she did an interview
with cuomo
this is about a month ago and she's up
at the governor's mansion
this is when i think that you know the
deaths from the nursing homes were much
more
raw for the families that were grieving
not a single question but a lot of
questions about his dating life and his
future for a possible presidential run
so i it's just extremely widespread it's
a remarkable pr
coup for governor cuomo i don't know if
anybody could ever repeat it
judge why don't you just run for
governor so we can just fix this
no no no thank you very much but
i'll tell you very quickly i think the
most the most disgusting part of this
was that
what the governor did do was he got a
bill passed that he signed into law that
pretty much gave immunity to all the
health care officials and everyone else
for civil and criminal cases uh as it
results
as as a result of what happened in the
nursing homes outrageous
outrageous he was warned he was told not
to send
infected patients in all of those people
died when they didn't have to die he
infected people in nursing homes
and he's on a publicity tour about the
size of his uh
nasal swab or whatever that was that his
brother was talking about
it's horrible yeah
i got one i got to give jake credit for
actually
doing that and it shows us glenn
greenwald says what happens if you're
not related to the governor
you can speak truth to power
well that's right because i think it's
not as if cuomo is without flaws greg
but you do have to say that
that daily briefing that he held proved
to be very popular because it was
informative i think he filled a vacuum
with information
a vacuum that people weren't getting
from the president and the second thing
to say is
remember you got a big city big state
and he did pull
down the curve that's a success
okay